in this video i'm going to show you
eight after effects tips and tricks that
i wish i knew when i was starting out
[Music]
hey there my name is cameron with motion
science and i've been using after
effects for over 20 years now and in
that time i've learned a lot of tips and
tricks to help me get better and more
efficient when using after effects so in
this video i'm going to show you eight
of those tips and tricks to help you
become more of a pro user in after
effects let's get started okay tip
number one the pan behind tool pan
behind tool is an awesome tool to use
for moving the anchor point so we can
move the anchor point anywhere in a
layer vector layer raster layer footage
layer and rotate from that anchor point
we can also scale from the anchor point
wherever that anchor point needs to be
the pan behind tool can move that anchor
point to that position
pan behind tool is also great for
footage so if i have an in and out point
set on my footage like we see in this
composition i can then drag left to
keep my in and out points the same but
move that footage further down my
timeline i can also drag right to move
my footage so if we have a set in and
out point like we're doing an edit we
can use the pan behind tool to drag left
and right to
adjust our footage within that in and
out point we can also shorten our out
point like we see here still drag our in
and out point and get our footage just
exactly how we need it with the pan
behind tool tip number two is replace
layer all we have to do is select a
footage layer a graphic layer in our
project file hold down alt or option and
drag on top of a layer in our timeline
and that layer is automatically updated
with
our new footage as you can see here it
keeps the same in and out points but
just replaces the layer we can also use
this replace layer with vector layers so
i can take this vector layer we see here
i can hold down alt or option drag and
replace my layer on my timeline as you
can see the anchor point the scale the
rotation it all remains the same on that
layer just a new graphic layer to
replace it tip number three continually
rasterize
so if we have any type of vector layer
we can scale it up as far as we want and
turn on continually rasterize and will
give us completely crisp edges to our
vector layer so as you can see here
the continually rasterized options
turned on if i turn it off we have a lot
of aliasing happening but if i turn it
on we've got crystal clear edges it
doesn't matter what we scale it to tip
number four continually rasterize can
also be used to break apart 3d pre comps
so what i have here is i have three
pre-comp layers and i've got some camera
movement here if you look within each of
these pre-comps you're going to see
there's multiple
3d layers positioned in 3d space as we
see here right there's different layers
pushed back in space and you can see
also example number two we've got
multiple layers back in space positioned
in z space and we've got precomp number
three
which is actually multiple precomps
positioned
in z space what we can do is by using
continually rasterize we can turn that
on and it's going to actually collapse
transformations and as you can see as
soon as i do that it gives us our depth
for our pre comps so our camera can move
around these pre comps and have lots of
layers in 3d space but we're only seeing
three pre comps in our timeline so it's
an easy way to keep your timeline tidy
and neat while working with lots of 3d
layers in after effects tip number five
let's say you want to see
your main composition but you also need
to see the pre-comp what's going on
inside the pre-comp at the same time
you're viewing your main composition to
do that all you have to do is go up here
to the top of your composition to where
it says the composition name
click and then click new comp viewer and
just like that you're gonna have two
compositions you're gonna be able to see
your main composition
in one window and your pre comp
in the other window this enables you to
work on adjusting elements inside your
pre comp while seeing how they affect
the overall composition
in your output comp tip number six so
let's say you want to have something
flicker on and off screen to do this you
have to set multiple keyframes you set a
keyframe for zero percent opacity and
then maybe you move forward two frames
and set a keyframe for 100 opacity you
move forward another frame zero percent
opacity
so on and so forth you can do this for
opacity you can do this for position
whatever it may be but there's a way
around having to add all of these extra
keyframes and that is through using hold
keyframes hold keyframes work by setting
a
normal keyframe then right clicking and
selecting hold keyframe what this does
is hold the value until we hit the next
keyframe so we can set one opacity
keyframe for zero percent move forward
two frames set a keyframe for a hundred
percent move forward a few frames again
set another keyframe for zero percent by
doing this the values are held until the
next keyframe is hit so in essence it
enables us to use half the keyframes
that we would normally have to use to do
a simple effect like a flicker effect
like we see here tip number seven so do
you ever experience a problem where you
set a keyframe for position you move
down the timeline set another keyframe
for another point
of position and then move to the end of
the timeline and set a third keyframe
and you'll notice that the center
keyframe has a little bit of a curve to
it and maybe you don't want to curve to
it maybe you just want the movement to
be
linear right with no curve there we just
want it to we want our ball to move from
position 1 to position 2 to position 3
all in a linear manner the way to fix
this is to go to after effects
preferences and under general you're
going to enable this preference right
here default spatial interpolation to
linear click ok
and now whenever you set keyframes
inside of after effects you can set a
keyframe at position one
a keyframe at position two
and a keyframe at position three and
you're gonna see there our motion path
is completely linear this is how i
work 100 of the time if i want a curve
added into my motion path i would rather
create that curve after the point than
have my keyframes
rove through space and creating
additional movement that i don't want to
have
and tip number eight anytime someone
asks you to send them the after effects
project file it's important that you
also bundle up any assets that are used
inside that project file the easy way to
do that is to go to file dependencies
collect files
and from here
you will need to save your project and
then you can select if you want to
collect source files for all the comps
or for selected comps it's completely up
to you
generally i'm using all comps because
i've reduced my project down to just
what i need
and by clicking collect you're going to
see here that this project file can be
collected there's four files 104
megabytes
and 12 effects and it's going to collect
the entire project file i can save it
out in a nice tidy folder structure here
and now i can compress this zip this
folder
and send it off to whomever
needs the project file this final tip is
going to save you a ton of time
what we have here is a project file that
i have set up
of how i like to work so i have my
output composition i have my comps my
precomps my working comps and i have a
folder structure for ae imports audio
edit footage pre-renders raster vectors
so on and so forth you can set this up
however you like to work then what
you're going to do is you're going to go
to file save as and save your project
file
anywhere on your local hard drive on any
external hard drive it doesn't matter
you're just going to save this after
effects project file out
anywhere on your computer
and give it the appropriate name and
after you've done that you're going to
go to your after effects preferences and
you're going to go to
new project preference here you're going
to choose your project template this is
going to be the file that you just saved
out and you're gonna select that file
click ok and that's all you have to do
now anytime you load up a new project
file this folder structure is going to
load up automatically with your
compositions whatever it is that you
like to have in your project files
they're going to load up here
immediately you don't have to set up new
folder structures
you don't have to set up new
compositions it's here it's ready to go
and you can start working i hope that
you really enjoy this lesson as much as
i loved teaching it so please let me
know if you have any questions in the
comments below i'd love to answer them
for you hit that like button if you
enjoyed this video and please subscribe
to this channel it helps other people
find this channel as well if you're
looking to upgrade your design skill set
master the art of style and execute like
a pro i have a course called stylecraft
that you can check out at
motionscience.tv you can also learn more
about this course by clicking the link
in the description below as always
thanks for watching my name is cameron
and this is motion science
[Music]
you